on the hill tonight for the giants will
be the left-hander sammy long making
this four start one-on-one on the year
look at the strikeouts 27 and 26 in the
third take your bats against sammy long
you're going to see a fastball that can
go low to mid 90s more mids than lows
long checks him now throws swing gonna
miss a fastball he blew it by him strike
three then he reached back that got a
little extra 93 miles an hour his first
few fastballs were in 1991
but that one right on the outside at 93
up a little bit as well and rogers was
very late
there goes joe the pitch strong out of
nist he struck him out with a change up
that was a beauty
it dipped down and below the knees
blackman tried to check his swing
couldn't do it kyle freeland on the hill
tonight for the rockies making start
number 15 has always had pretty good
luck against the giants at 15 starts the
rockies are nine and six behind him he
is six and three lifetime 0-2 pitch
strike three called on the inside edge
bill miller with a generous strike zone
from austin slater's perspective but
it's a three-pitch strikeout for
freeland
2-2 swag and a miss got him upstairs
with a fastball
kyle freeland a 10 pitch first inning
with a pair of punch outs no score as we
head to the second
sammy long goes back to work against the
rocky's first baseman cj crone 2-1
is sent down the right side with some
carrie bryant going back looking up and
it gets over the brick wall and is out
of here touch him all time opposite
field for cj krone 19th home run for
crow came off the bat at 107 107.4 miles
an hour 3-2 pitch swinging to miss he
struck him out with a high fastball
and that was very high and dazza went
after it
so two down and long throws
curveball
strike three call in the outside corner
sammy long has four strikeouts
in two innings but the rockies have gone
ahead
on the crone home run batting fifth
third baseman number ten evan longoria
so nice reception for evan longoria as
you would expect from our giants fans
pop them
up may have a shot on this but he's
taking a different route and longoria is
hot right now folks
look out
i mean that the wind blew that at least
40 feet at least
one two pitch swag and a miss he just
threw the fastball by him strikeout
number three for kyle freeland and the
giants have two men on with two men out
and donovan solano coming up
have done so well
of scoring early in games two odd two
out two two pitch ground ball past the
mound up the middle base head center
field
longoria rounding third and he'll score
the tying run
donnie barrels ties it up all right once
again giants getting that two out rbi
base hit gabe kepler looking to grab the
lead now he's got alex dickerson pinch
hitting for sammy long
and dickerson sends it in the air to
left center field and
fighting the win connor joe was there to
make the catch and end the inning giants
tie it on a two out hit your pitcher now
for the giants zach lately and how often
do you see a guy who was the closer in
last night's ball game got to save come
into tonight's ball game in the third
inning well that's exactly what mattel
is doing
the o2 story takes strike three call
right there on the outside 96 miles an
hour two down mattel's first strikeout
littell ready now he throws blackman
strikes out swinging fastball got him so
zach will tell another strong inning of
relief and up comes darren ruff who
grounded out his first time up 3-2 pitch
is a called strike three got it on the
outside corner at the knees ruff can't
believe it but freeland fans darren ruff
and the one-two pitch to longoria swing
and a miss got him on a ball in the dirt
and kyle freeland winds up striking out
the side he leaves two aboard in the
third
hitting eighth in the order kyle
freeland the pitcher for the rockies is
on deck one to one fifth inning
as a swing and a miss he struck him out
on a high fastball
three strikeouts for
littell
the tell throws
and a fastball right down the middle
strikes recall
that ball was right down the embarcadero
right down california street
shoot right down geary two down base is
empty here's connor joe the lead off man
he's walked and lined out to right and
he hits a fly ball to right field coming
over to his left is bryant toward the
foul line now he's in a hurry as he gets
to the line and makes the catch dominic
leon third pitcher of the game for the
giants inning number six
this is a broken back looper make it 16
straight
a lead off single in a 1-1 game and
brendan rodgers is hitting 16 straight
best streak going in the game now
they're loaded up for the owner of three
grand slams already this year cj crone
2-2 little slow roller up the middle
crawford will flip at the second for one
relay to first not in time
run scores as rogers crosses the plate
one pitch to mack is bounced up the
middle off the glove of solano and
everybody is safe home comes trevor's
story and the rockies take a three to
one lead evan longoria scored the giants
run one on one out pitches bounce
towards third mcmahon goes to second for
one rogers to first another double play
six
gutsy innings from kyle freeland
for the 40th time this year harley and
garcia coming into a game 49 strikeouts
and 43
innings pitched
fourth man out of the bullpen after long
went two innings
and ryan hits it up the middle grabbed
by crawford he tags the runner throws to
first not in time and a run scores
ryan mcmahon's hustle
enables the rockies to get a fourth run
daniel bart will be asked to nail down
the save this will be appearance number
46. five wins five losses 4.14
era and the pitch
swing a smash into right center field
base head crawford got a first pitch 98
mile an hour fastball and he was right
on it 2-2 swang and a miss he got him to
chase a breaking ball out of the strike
zone and that's the ball game
the rockies
end their losing streak and stop the
winning run of the giants in a
hard-fought well-deserved 4-1 victory